avec son million et demi de visiteurs
c'est le premier site touristique de la
région le zoo de beauval a rouvert
aujourd'hui pour la première fois depuis
sept mois
et c'est un événement 800 espèces à
redécouvrir
en attendant peut être une nouvelle
naissance chez les pandas rémy carton
nous fait la visite à beauval les stars
du jour n'étaient pas les pandas géants
mais les visiteurs après un long
confinement le parc de saint-aignan
retrouve son public
un soulagement pour les équipes du zoo
mais aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour ont
ré ouvre nos portes après sept mois de
fermeture c'est un moment extrêmement
émouvant l'air très heureux de pouvoir à
enfants accueillir de nouveau à nos
visiteurs en haut de leur plateforme les
sens je redécouvre les habitués du zoo
et des visiteurs plus atypiques à
beauval la fermeture a permis de
réaliser des travaux pour améliorer le
lieu de vie des animaux et proposer des
nouveautés aux visiteurs ces travaux
nous en avons fait deux
beaucoup nous avons notamment rénover
totalement uda sein des manchots donc
nouveau décor nouvelles fini tration
afin de garantir une qualité d'eau
parfaite pour nos animaux pendant ces
deux années de vie 20 en 2022
nous allons nous efforcer de relever
toutes les dernières installations un
peu ancienne qui date des débuts de
beauvais pour limiter les risques
sanitaires et ne pas perturber les
animaux
la jauge d'accueil a été réduite de
moitié les visiteurs peuvent profiter de
la serre équatoriale inauguré en 2020
tout comme des nacelles qui permettent
de survoler le vaste parc où résident
plus de 800 espèces animales la jauge a
aussi été réduite de moitié pour les
spectacles comme ici avec les maîtres
des airs le spectacle d'oiseaux lancés
en 2010 est un possible d'arpenter
beauval sans rendre visite un one one
le panda géant qui va peut-être avoir
bientôt un nouveau petit c'est compliqué
les pandas la reproduction
alors on avait effectivement des
accouplements et une insémination sur la
femelle qui s'est très très bien passé
maintenant assuré qu' à gestation ou pas
ou on ne sait même pas encore c'est très
compliqué chez la femelle panda une des
curiosités du zoo se situe dans l'enclos
des pandas la petite téa est né juste
avant le confinement et découvre le
public
t as l'a quasiment pas vu le public de
piqué qui avait calé en fait qu on se
cale est née en juillet ensuite il ya eu
elle était dans la poche et elle est
sortie il n'y avait pas de public mais
ça va pas la déranger je pense étant
donné que sa maman prenez le public
sa mère va la rassurer donc il y aura
aucun problème avec avec le public
les visiteurs ne sont pour l'instant que
quelques milliers à beauval pas de quoi
perturber le sommeil de théa qui semble
aussi sereine que le roi des animaux